tal y como se esperaba la unión europea
no reconoce el resultado de las
elecciones legislativas en venezuela los
cancilleres europeos han constatado que
los comicios no fueron ni creíbles ni
transparentes y que carecen de toda
legitimidad ya que en gran parte la
oposición no formó parte de ellos así
que ahora mismo la unión europea tiene
la vista puesta en la fecha del 5 de
enero día en que se disuelve la asamblea
nacional dirigida por juan guaidó el
jefe de la diplomacia europea se ocurre
y ha avanzado que hablará con el grupo
internacional de contacto formada por
países europeos también con países de la
región como argentina y ecuador para
abordar qué tipo de futuro le espera al
país si se puede encontrar realmente una
solución política al conflicto actual
así como hablar también del papel futuro
que se le se reserva a partir de ahora a
juan guaidó que está reconocido como
presidente encargado por más de 60
países